un projet de vacances projet de quoi
place même si entrevoir l'avenir à 2 a
toujours été un peu compliqué pour
laurent et stéphane un couple qui au
regard de la loi et d autres vies au
seuil de la marginalité
actuellement notre couple n'est pas
reconnu bon et bien vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur
lorsqu'on se présente ou lorsqu'on
remplit des papiers on coche dans la
classe célibataire on est célibataire
l'extérieur et ça c'est pas vrai ça
correspond pas à la réalité et ça
voudrait dire quelque part que notre
couple est marginal or nous on n'est pas
des marginaux
le contrat d'union social va donner un
statut juridique à leur couple un statut
qui leur permettra de faire du projet de
ça permet d'avoir notamment à droite au
bail commun lorsqu'on cherche un
appartement vis-à-vis de la banque aussi
ça permet de se présenter en tant que
couple fiscalité héritage ou tout
simplement possibilité de suivre son
partenaire en cas de mutation
et puis surtout obligation de secours et
d'assistance
j'ai des obligations à son à son égard
donc c'est très fort comme geste
l'un vers l'autre quoi puis c'est aussi
un geste vers la société c'est montrer
que bach on est bien ensemble que on
s'aime et puis que et puis que c'est
comme ça et puis c'est bien c'est plutôt
sympathique quan un contrat d'union pas
de mariage exclut aussi l'adoption où
l'insémination artificielle ce contrat
se veut laïc et républicain sans
distinction de sexe alors ça peut être
des couples sexuée homosexuels
hétérosexuels ça peut être également des
étudiants qui partagent une chambre des
personnes âgées des hébergeants et d
héberger des situations tout à fait
multiples et diverses
le contrat d'union se fera en mairie
devant un officier d'état civil
dès le vote de la loi
[Musique]